last night when it became clear that
Donald Trump was going to win the
presidency thousands of Americans went
on the Canadian citizen immigration
website so many Americans in fact the
few website crashed it's been in the
news yeah it just now if you're one of
those people who's seriously considered
moving to Canada my good friend Andy
Richter has a message for you Andy
thanks Conan I know that you feel
America Trump wins and you think well
maybe moose meets not that gaming but it
is so if you're a liberal Democrat and
you want to move to a foreign land
that's more open-minded and progressive
than the United States why not consider
moving north to California
[Applause]
California borders the rest of the
United States you don't need a passport
to get there and check out these liberal
perks yesterday we legalized marijuana
we voted for Hillary tesla's are made
here plastic bags are banned half our
cities have Spanish names and thanks to
proposition 60 torn actors can bone
without condoms if you moved north to
California you're as far away for as you
can get from Washington DC which on this
map is in the deep south and did I
mention that weed is legal trust me guys
that's gonna be muy importante in the
years to come back to you Conan thanks
[Applause]
well the important to cross in front of
my camera weld the wire that was
supposed to fly me in fear hope so I had
to do it the old-fashioned way
you